the lush green of britain's farming
fields
the romantic view of home-grown produce
but this crop is contentious
steve baron's fields are full of hemp a
type of cannabis plant
it's moving really fast at this time of
year the seeds have just been planted
that's a little seed a little cannabis
plant seed
yes that'll be a big flower next year
but the harvest will be
hampered under the terms of his license
steve will only be allowed to use the
plants stalks
and seeds the real value is found in the
leaves and flowers
non-psychotic cbd oil used in a booming
wellness market
but those will end up here on a fire
forcibly destroyed
a totally legal product to sell illegal
for most british farmers to produce
it feels ridiculous actually every other
plant
in this country you can get all the
value from it
it's so much tough work growing and
being a farmer anyway
to then be restricted and told you
not that bit leave that bit alone but
you can
import it these are the cannabis seeds
planted here in the spring
and harvested in the late summer when
they've grown into huge bushy cannabis
plants
under the current regulations a field of
roughly this size might turn a farmer
about 12 000 pounds if they're allowed
to harvest the whole plant
that would rise to as much as a hundred
thousand
and there's no shortage of potential
buyers we made some chocolates at one
point
brownies gummies we even made a
cbd kind of prosecco cbd is big business
the market here is projected to more
than triple in the next four years
joe is one of many entrepreneurs in the
space who has to import his key
ingredient
from america i wish it would come from a
uk supplier
which would lower the co2 emissions
the distance the cost including
paperwork etc
it would also bring jobs to the uk it
would allow our quality
standards to be within the uk and those
standards
will be key ensuring bad practice isn't
legalized
likely one reason for delay
professionalization say this farm is the
future
they hope this greenhouse will soon grow
cannabis
there's a lot of regulatory changes that
need to happen in order to create a safe
legal and a transparent supply chain for
cbd in the uk
for us it's an opportunity really to
apply the same rigor that we apply to
our core business and bring that to sort
of
uk growing cbd production there are many
rules which regulate these plants
many protect the public others say some
are just outdated and unfair
helen and smith sky news cambridgeshire